[Music]
i honestly can say that the whole
pregnant time i was pregnant i was
nervous because i was like i almost feel
like i don't deserve this beautiful
privilege i almost feel like
i honestly got a lot of anxiety because
i thought for somebody who said their
whole life that they didn't want to be a
mom and hear this gift was being given
to me i'm
beyond grateful because i cannot believe
as every parent will tell you how much a
child changes your life and i like
myself better as a mom the only part of
it that was
i would say um
i could have done without was the
postpartum anxiety it was
honestly it was treacherous because
nobody told me that there's postpartum
anxiety i went home
from my doctors with a checklist and
then from the hospital with another
checklist that
really details what postpartum
depression is so as i'm
checking every day that i'm not crying
i'm not suicidal i'm not um
uh
wanting to stay in bed all day like i
was out and about i was happy being a
mom i was excited but i was intensely
worried the day monica was born i got yo
i got i freaked out i shut everything
down we were like no cameras no nothing
i'm on my fourth month now and i'm
i i got some help i did i did get you
know i saw a psychologist tonight that's
great yes and i talked to more moms and
more moms told me about postpartum
anxiety not depression totally different
jeezy and i are a team and so
no matter what comes at us even with the
baby i mean
that first miscarriage was was really
painful and it made me realize
gosh like this
this is not easily given to anybody
that's right do you think that having a
baby was it was the the right man at the
right time in the right place absolutely
i mean
the great thing about our love is
we have flaws
but we embrace working through them i've
never had that with me before right and
being imperfectly
perfect made it much more exciting let's
talk about jobs because you always have
jobs that's the thing like genie works
it's about to get hot hot hot holy moly
is back new episodes air tuesdays on abc
tell me about the new season holy moly
is an intense
high octane
crazier bigger than life golf course
that has nothing to do with golf
what is it like playing opposite the
muppets how about having miss piggy in
our dressing room she is the one and
done true diva what can we talk about
the real the final episode airs june 3rd
you were there from the start how hard
is that to let go it's hard because
the show is the first of its kind when
you have a show that is by minority
voices for minority voices if we open
doors for other shows like that to be in
production i'm excited about that i want
to see that happen
when people ask me like what's it feel
like being you know one of the only
vietnamese americans in tv it feels
lonely it doesn't feel great you know so
i want to open that up more for the aapi
community
and at the same time
i'm proud of the reel for what we did we
were iconic
[Music]
you